what's up everyone welcome to program
your Mon today we're gonna be looking at
a GM ignition key programming procedure
now this particular procedure fits many
different vehicles if you're unsure what
procedure your vehicle takes you can
visit our web-site program auto keys
comm so a couple things before we get
into it the first thing is this
procedure is gonna be if you've lost all
the keys for your vehicle when you do
this when you program in this new key it
will erase any that you've previously
had so this is gonna be for all keys
lost if you need to just add a key
without erasing your old ones we've
actually done that video before and I'll
put that the first link in the
description box of the video so we've
got that covered the next thing we need
to do is make sure we have our blade cut
this is a new key unprogrammed but you
need to have the blade cut all your two
places your two options for that are
gonna be a dealership or an automotive
locksmith so once we have those two
things
the third thing being you need to lot
yourself about thirty minutes this is a
timed procedure it's gonna take you
probably 30 to 35 minutes so just make
sure you have your enough time before
you start um so I think that should do
it once we have ourselves to that point
where we have our new unprogrammed key
with the blade cut we can get into the
next step okay so now we're ready to
started we have our new on programs key
and then I have a phone here that I'm
gonna use the time myself so what we
need to do is go ahead and put the key
in the ignition turn to the on position
and we're gonna leave it in the on
position so now I'm gonna go ahead and
press start here this first part is
gonna take ten minutes and what we're
gonna be looking at actually is for the
security light to go at and the security
light is that right there so at about
the ten minute mark that light is gonna
go off so we're at about 17 seconds here
I'll go ahead and check back in once we
get closer to the ten minute mark okay
so we're getting close to our 10 minute
mark here or go ahead and just we're
actually at 9:50 so we're gonna keep an
eye on this security light here again
we're waiting for that to go out
as you saw there it just turned off so
now you want to take your ignition and
turn it to off I'm gonna turn it back to
on leave back on and we're gonna do the
exact same thing we'll go ahead and
reset our timer and we'll see you in
another 10 minutes so we're coming up on
our second ten minute mark we're at
about nine minutes 50 seconds now the
light just turned off so we're gonna
turn it to off turn the back to on and
we need to do it one more time reset our
timer and we'll see in 10 minutes so now
we're getting into our third and final
ten minute mark and before we get there
and you just want to give you guys a
heads up that on the security light on
the third time it may look a little
different instead of just going out it
may flash once it may keep flashing
repeatedly or it may just simply go out
the main thing you want to keep an eye
on is your ten minute mark and then just
look for a change in the security light
so now we reached our third and final
ten minute mark so now we're gonna turn
our key to off we're going to turn it to
on and now our key should be programmed
let's go ahead just take the key out and
start it to test and you kind of notice
there I've noticed when you first
program in the new key you almost have
to start it it feels like for an extra
second or two hold it cranked forward so
if you have any questions please let me
know if you could take a second to like
and subscribe helps us out and we'd
appreciate it thank you